I'm Kennedy I'm Bill hemmer I'm Sandra
Smith and this is the Fox News Rundown
Friday December 9th 2022 I'm Chris
Foster American basketball star Brittany
Greiner is freed in a prisoner swap of
the Russian government it was a gift to
them to
them pressure on the Bible ministration
gets
we're speaking with Fox News Sunday host
Shannon bream I'm
getting ripped off so we're breaking
down seasonal scams including which
clicks could be tricks you're cruising
around on Facebook Instagram wherever
and you're feeling giving it's the
holiday season you want to be generous
it makes you feel good and you see a
link that comes your way and I'm David
Marcus I've got the final word on the
Fox News Rundown
[Music]
Brittany Greiner spent 294 days in
Russian custody since her arrested an
airport with cannabis oil in her luggage
President Biden at the White House
yesterday announcing her release in a
prisoner swap standing together with her
my Cheryl and the Oval Office I spoke
with Brittany Greiner
she's safe she's on a plane she's on her
way home after months of being unjustly
detained in Russia held under on
tolerable circumstances the exchange for
Russian arms dealer Victor boot does not
include the return of another American
Paul Whalen in Russian custody since
2018. this was not a choice of which
American to bring home
the choice was one
or none Secretary of State Anthony
blinken and the president say the
Russians are treating weyland's case
differently as an accused spy we're
Overjoyed to get any American home but
we know there are many others who are
still stuck out there so it is the best
possible news for Brittany Greiner and
her loved ones Shannon bream's the host
of Fox News Sunday Paul Whalen remains
stuck there in Russia and there are
others around the globe that the
administration says we're going to keep
working on those two those are the tough
conversations you got to have because
when you look at Victor Booth who's been
called The Merchant of death and someone
who deals in arms and um sells to
terrorists that for a lot of people is
going to feel like the wrong trade for
Brittany Greiner again we want every
American to get home that we can and
listen weyland's family has been very I
think
um kind about this saying like we're
thrilled for her but I think when you
look at what appears to many people to
be a lopsided trade I'm sure they're
wondering why their loved one couldn't
have been in the balance too yeah I mean
I guess in the end to give you know
credit or whatever to the Biden
Administration apparently the deal was
this is the deal you aren't getting Paul
Whalen for big Victor Boot and so if you
want grinder you get Greiner and that's
and that's the deal yeah so the body
Administration says we continue having
these conversations um with Russia and
you just have to wonder um if they would
have had better leverage if Brittney
Griner wasn't caught in the middle of
this she's a recognizable prominent
professional athlete and so for the
Russians it was a gift when she walked
through there with something in her
luggage that was you know illegal there
um you know she even pled guilty and
said listen I made a horrible mistake I
never intended to break your laws I hope
that me pleading guilty will help
instead she's sentenced for years to a
penal colony in the middle of nowhere it
was a gift to them to have an American
that was so prominent and had such
prominent Defenders and Friends calling
for her release that it put pressure on
the bite Administration to get something
done Supreme Court this week Shannon I
know your Supreme Court Aficionado uh
there was an elections case and
religious freedom slash freedom of
speech case let's start with the
elections case
um it could have major implications
what's your read on it it could um I
think the justices gosh this was slated
for 90 minutes it went for three hours
they're really struggling with where to
draw the line here because the
Constitution as folks know says that
state legislatures are the ones who get
to set the parameters and the guidelines
for how to conduct Federal elections in
their state so it comes up in the
context of these State legislatures
drawing these voting district Maps them
getting thrown out by a state court or a
state court judge and then being redrawn
so the you know it's this the theory at
the heart of the case is the independent
state legislature do they alone get to
decide issues surrounding Federal
elections or can a state court step in
and say listen you can't do these crazy
super gerrymander districts and we're
going to step in here
um so gosh it was a showdown and I I
couldn't tell you exactly what's going
to happen from the arguments I don't
think that independent state legislature
Theory which is considered pretty out
there is going to survive but where do
you draw the line between the state
legislature and any other entity the
state level that would be able to put a
check on them with regard to these
federal election issues yeah and there's
also a read that the founding fathers
when they refer to state legislators
were referring to not just the body the
legislative body but the entire
legislative process everybody involved
including the courts including Governors
vetoes and was with a lot of these
things
um with originalism we don't really know
and that's what they were trying to you
know go through so much of this it's
interesting because you know the people
who are into textualism or originalism
will say like what the text says that's
it and then there are these arguments
about the history what the framers
actually meant where they use these
words in other places to give us a more
full understanding of what they might
have meant there so
um listen the the left side of the
argument is that you know State Court
should be able to step in and shut down
legislatures when they do crazy things
you know further on the right end of the
spectrum is that support for that theory
that it was all about the state
legislatures meaning the lawmakers alone
I don't think that straight out position
has a chance of winning I think the
Nuance is going to be somewhere in
between yeah I mean you use the word
crazy and who's to say where that line
is what's crazy to some isn't to others
and right but it happens it happens in
both directions for either party because
look in New York the state legislature
came back with maps there that the state
court said these are cuckoo Town
partisan there's no way these super
democrat-drawn districts are going to
survive they sent it back a couple of
times and finally the court said all
right you're not doing it a special
Master is going to redraw these made the
districts much more competitive and it
was probably very helpful to House
Republicans who flipped a number of
those House Seats yeah I mean if the the
people who are in favor of this Theory
got their way then that wouldn't have
happened and Republicans might have lost
those seats
um another this other case is Colorado
website designer sort of I guess
preemptively asking to not take on gay
wedding clients how is this one
different than the Colorado Baker that
didn't want to make gay wedding cakes a
few years ago the court weighed in on
a couple of things here first of all all
um the reason in part that she went
preemptively because you know
pre-inforcement challenges are not super
common at the Supreme Court meaning you
have to have somebody who's gotten in
trouble and then now suing over the law
but for her also there's part of this
law that says you cannot express
derogatory views on a particular
protected class so she wanted to put on
her website hey I want to do wedding
websites but as a Christian this is why
I won't do same-sex wedding websites I
have respect she says she's got plenty
of lgbtq clients she just don't won't do
wedding websites for them and so she
felt and her legal team felt like the
law barred her from even putting an
explanation on her website in advance
about why she would only do certain
websites so I think that got them in the
door although there were a couple
questions about whether this case was
ripe but at the end of the day this is a
free speech case versus a one about
religious liberty they're kind of
intertwined here but what she's saying
is the government can never compel
anyone whether it's pro-lgbt causes
anti-lgbt causes pro-abortion
anti-abortion like the government can
never compel someone one to give a
certain kind of speech or to sign off on
something they don't agree with and so
that's her argument here is that she
would be forced to use her artistic
abilities to endorse something or to
give speech to something she doesn't
support yeah so for example if she had a
I don't know a generic template say for
for a wedding
um she would have to sell that to
everyone uh but but she but she can't be
but she thinks I shouldn't be forced to
create something specifically for a gay
wedding yeah just like um the cake baker
which there you know the case came down
in his favor but it didn't really
resolve the questions it said that he'd
been mistreated by the Colorado court
system and the enforcement mechanisms
they had there but yes they they both
say we'll sell to anyone but these
customized Creations is a different
thing Justice Barrett I believe was the
one who asked her and said well this
isn't so much about you know whether
it's a heterosexual or same-sex couple
or whatever would you turn away things
that you just don't agree with your
faith she says I won't do violent
websites and the question was what if on
the wedding website you know where
people say our story or how we met what
if they said we want you to craft our
story and it's that we were married to
other people we met in the workplace we
had an affair and we fell in love and
her legal representative said no she's
not going to do that website either and
Justice Gorsuch kind of boiled it down
this way he said so you're saying it's
not about who it's about what so it's
not about who you will or won't serve
it's about the message the what you will
or will not promote and I will see where
the votes come together on that issue
um as we now know we sort of predicted
last week without saying it outright
that Raphael warlock was going to keep
his senate seat in Georgia so now it's
Democrats 51 Republicans 49 instead of
50 50. you can say look they already
sort of had a majority with 50 50 with
vice president Harris as the
tie-breaking vote but they're really
there are practical reasons that 51 is a
lot more than 50. I mean even if you
look at things like committee
assignments that kind of stuff but also
when you've had Joe manchin kind of be
the king maker here in Washington
because everybody's fighting for his
vote it takes a little bit of that angst
away from the Democrats because they
don't have to convince Joe manchin or
get his vote on all these really tough
issues takes away a little bit of his
leverage I mean you have Kirsten Cinema
and kind of that mix too but Joe manchin
has really been the thorn in the side
for Democrats and at 51 they don't have
to have his vote to get some things done
President Biden said the other day just
to wrap this up said on Tuesday uh there
are more important things going on when
asked why he didn't wasn't visiting the
Border he was going to Arizona for for
other reasons and didn't make a border
stop opponent say look this is more
proof that his priorities are off they
say what's more important than border
security and so now he's been hammered
on that for a few days
and to the people who live along those
borders regardless of party I mean
they've been begging for help and have
talked about how things have gotten
exponentially worse and listen you can
just go by objective data that comes
from non-partisan agencies within the
government it's the worst it's been and
and that's just a nonpartisan assessment
of hard data and facts but when you hear
from the folks down there these ranchers
and people who live along the border I
mean they are in a situation where
they're begging any Administration
anyone in Washington to listen to them
you've got folks that can require a
Democrat who just got reelected down
there in Texas
um who was repeatedly called out the
administration you've got other members
out there saying yes this is our
president our Democrat leader of our
party needs to get down there and see
what's going on it's it's unconscionable
that he's not down there so it's not
just Republicans saying that this is an
issue Democrats say it as well and when
the president visits a border state and
doesn't go to the Border I think that's
a very specific decision yeah is there
any I guess a non-decision is a decision
um is there any hope of any kind of
immigration reform uh coming in the next
two years I don't know I mean it
levels they haven't been able to find a
place to meet that all you've got
divided House and Senate now with
parties controlling the two different
chambers you also are going into a
presidential election year where neither
side is going to want to give the other
a huge win but you know the the Border
has gotten astronomically bad and
dangerous we've got this flow of
fentanyl into the country that is taking
hundreds tens of thousands
um lives here in the in the U.S and so I
think that if we can appeal to the good
nature of our representatives and
Senators they need to get to the table
now what the administration will say is
on day one this is the first thing that
bind Administration offered up well yes
you can offer things up and you know if
it's a messaging bill or you know
there's no chance you're getting any
votes across the aisle which you need I
don't know how genuine that is but the
two sides have got to get it together
and they they need each other to get
something done but going into a
presidential election year I don't know
how much the political motivation will
be there Shannon bream host of Fox News
Sunday have a good show thanks for
coming on thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is David Marcus with your Fox News
commentary coming up
Shoppers hit the ground running this
holiday season both in person and
remotely basically everything I could
buy online putting up some record early
numbers in a Holiday Rush driven by more
than one factor says Emory University
marketing Professor Doug Bowman people
being concerned about inflation and you
know maybe prices will continue to go up
and a combination of last year's issues
around stockouts unfortunately this also
adds up to a lot of opportunity for
scammers who keep coming up with new and
improved ways to trick people's money
away the Better Business Bureau says
more than a third of online retail fraud
reports involve fake websites even more
40 percent are from email and social
media you know one of the biggest things
that we're looking out for at least this
year is the real growth in the scam
where you're simply presented with
buying an object at a great price and
then there's a link saying in order to
get this price you have to send it to us
electronically you can't use your credit
card tech journalist Kurt Knutson is
known as the Cyber guy so you're going
to use PayPal or you can venmo this to
us but you can't use your credit card
let that be a big red flag and I think
we're already seeing a couple hundred
million dollars estimated and those kind
of scams just as holiday season alone
wow so that sounds that sounds like kind
of a phishing scam sure because what
they're trying to do is bait you into
clicking a link and handing over cash
and of course you never get the product
because it was a scam all along wow
um and that's not the only package scam
in town
um so to speak I mean for a while we
heard a lot about packages just being
stolen outside homes this package scam
seems like something that's really been
an evolving threat what else is
happening with packages now
Lisa I'm going to pull up a text that I
got that I literally was targeted by
that's going around to tons of people as
well and the text reads this your
delivery address is unusual your package
is stuck at the Sorting Center please
update your address by clicking this
link of course you click that link it
goes to some scam website they're trying
to gather more information from you to
scam you in one way or another or to put
malware on your device so right there
game over you're you're the sucker at
that point uh because there's really no
connection back to that so again
the advice here is if you get a notice
like that and you didn't ask for it it
comes by text or by email
don't click the link unless you
specifically ask for that to be sent to
you right then instead go back to where
you bought whatever it is that you think
hasn't been delivered yet look up your
order history and track it from there
don't click the link in the email or a
text click it from the official website
or when they link you to a proper like
UPS or FedEx uh link for tracking that's
such an Insidious one too because so
many of us are so pressed for time we're
in a big Holiday Rush are there ways to
spot that that's not a valid text what
are the red flags to look for
so having the proper anti-virus
protection on all your devices is really
essential what that'll do in most cases
this will have been flagged already and
then when that link came to my phone and
by the way I you the phone I had was
using did not have this protection on it
does now because it made that link so
that I couldn't click it and it sent a
little alert that said we think this is
suspicious so having that kind of
protection and getting good anti-virus
on all your devices is really the way to
go because nine out of ten times it's
gonna have already caught this so that
when we're living our busy lives they're
doing the protecting for us and so that
stops this activity from getting in and
I guess failing then if you don't have
it for some reason or haven't taken that
step yet you want to look for kind of
the details like you could see if it's
not really coming from a legitimate
Source maybe they have a letter or two
off or they have bad grammar there's
usually something that tips it off but I
mean they are getting better her at
looking legitimate so it's tough well
they're using they're ripping off logos
I mean if they had put a UPS logo on
that text I got I probably would have
really thought that seems legit what
actually caught my eye is that when they
said like please please click this link
they didn't spell out the word please
they put PLS abbreviated which is a
little too casual for a company to be
communicating with a customer so that
was a red flag for me a lot of people
making donations this time of year
scammers know this how do we make sure
we're donating to real charities
so largely on social media right now
you're cruising around on Facebook
Instagram wherever and you're feeling
giving it's the holiday season you want
to be generous it makes you feel good
and you see a link that comes your way
uh that somebody reposed to a great
organization that makes all I want to
help the people of the Ukraine oh this
is makes complete sense I just have to
click and donate a few bucks here do not
click anything in social media as it
relates to a charity and forgiving this
year most of it not all of it most of it
is very suspicious just take that extra
beat in life and say okay let me be more
generous for my time and myself right
now to give in the right way which is
simply go on a Google and look up that
charity find the official website and
obviously they're going to have links
directly from their website to make a
donation instead of clicking inside of a
text email or on any of these social
media scams that we're seeing going
around and it's done instead of you just
giving your money to some crook I know
online versions of secret Santa have
been popular as well the idea being you
know you get a gift but you also pay it
forward that seems inherently risky
should you only do this with people you
know or is there a safe way to do this
uh you know new high-tech version of
Secret Santa
so I haven't received one of these but
I've seen plenty of them in our research
which is take the game secret Santa that
we've played many times in life and now
it's really gone viral online where
people are suggesting to just play
secret Santa with a stranger it seems
giving it seems like okay Pay It Forward
kind of gamified giving
but don't do it it's a scam it's a
pyramid scam that goes nowhere it'll say
for example you know click here send a
bottle of 12 bottle of wine to somebody
make them feel good and then they'll get
the opportunity to pass that along to
someone else too everybody has a lovely
drink and we all feel warm and fuzzy
except in this case nobody's getting any
wine and nobody's doing anything but
taking your credit card information or
your payment however you sent it and
saying toodaloo after that so it's a
scam so the only time to really
participate in gift exchanges that are
online is when they come from people you
already know and you know it's them and
it's not somebody who got a hold of
their email analogy pretending to be
them so best to do it in real life not
as safe online
for many people it's gift cards to the
rescue but even those are not immune
from scams what is what's the problem
with gift cards
well here's a deal where do we get gift
cards mostly it's mostly at the checkout
you'll see like uh especially this time
of year you go to the grocery store
drugstore the problem is these crooks
are going in person into these stores
and they will cleverly slice open the
packaging for the gift card they'll
remove the back part that is a
verification code and then they will
steal that so that when it's activated
later when you buy it and the funds get
in there they get an alert the funds go
in the card when you check out and they
drain it seconds later you then give the
card to somebody you're hoping to be
generous to and they say well thanks a
lot but it had no value on it so you've
created all kinds of problems where you
didn't really give a gift and then you
got ripped off at the same time and by
the time you figure it out it's done so
the answer here is look extremely
carefully at each gift card that you
decide to buy right now make sure that
it is intact that the packaging is
sealed all the the way around that it
hasn't been resealed and just be an
inspector when you're looking at it and
then when you're checking out make sure
that that part of the card if you can
see it has not been scratched out that
reveals the activation number that you
would have to put in to use it later
playing again a gift card for someone
online and having it sent to them is
that safer are there yeah so much safer
so when you again go to the source so
don't go buy a gift card from a gift
card company online because while there
may be enticements like hey you'll earn
extra points in this those things might
be legitimate but at the same time you
don't have as many protections as when
you buy it directly from the source cut
out the middle man go as if you say it's
let's say it's Home Depot or let's say
it's Lowe's or wherever you're buying it
go directly to the Home Depot website go
to directly to the Lowe's website and
buy it directly from them you can have
it shipped to you you then send it to
them hand it to them or they will do an
electronic version especially as we get
late in the season and it's Christmas
Eve and you're saying uh oh I forgot
Aunt Harriet I'm going to send her off
to the mall and you know I'll find a
store she's going to Macy's now so that
can be electronically sent to her and
then you just say hey I just did this
for you I thought it'd be easier if you
got it electronically and just make sure
you got the email I love you
I wanted to ask you one more thing I'm
almost afraid of what the answer will be
to be honest
um but how safe are we shopping on store
websites or Amazon for instance have
scammers been able to infiltrate every
part of the online purchasing process at
this point
so when we use our credit cards not a
debit card but we use our credit cards
and we never use say a link to a payment
service where we're surrendering cash
instantly to somebody else that we have
no recourse on is the safest way to go
no matter where you're shopping whether
online or in person the use of a credit
card in our country fortunately we have
protection so you're never ever liable
for more than fifty dollars on any
fraudulent activity most credit card
companies will Zero it out as you know
but you've got to really scour your
bills especially after the holiday
season when in January all your
purchases start to show up on your
credit card statement have a closer look
at it make sure those are legit make
sure it's the amount that you paid for
it this is the time that people scam
those things and then avoid using a
debit card if you can and also
cash may be king but cash is never never
something you should use online in terms
of sending cash electronically where you
have no rights and you don't know really
who's getting it hopefully people can
have a safer holiday season with all of
your tips many many thanks Kurt Knutson
the Cyber guy thank you very much for
all of your Insight Thank you Lisa and
also you can go to foxnews.com Tech and
we'll have all these tips for you there
and you can also find a link to sign up
for the Cyber guide newsletter there or
at cyberguy.com Fantastic Kurt thank you
so much
[Music]
and now some good news with Tanya J
powers
a new training program at the University
of Pennsylvania is playing a crucial
role in the lives of veterans their
training service dogs and it doesn't
just help veterans who need a service
animal it also helps other veterans who
benefit from doing the training the
Philadelphia Inquirer reports that the
program is a partnership with a
non-profit Warrior K-9 connection which
describes its work as mission-based
trauma recovery dogs are bred
specifically for the program and are
mostly Labradors and golden retrievers
breeds that are good at helping veterans
with both mental and physical
disabilities the dogs learn a variety of
things from how to soothe an anxious
owner to comforting veterans who are
uncomfortable in crowds the dog acting
as a barrier between their owner and
large groups of people the full training
for the dogs last two years with
veterans taking eight weeks stints to
help teach the dogs 70 to 90 commands
before the dogs are matched with a
veteran as a permanent service dog all
the dogs in the program are named after
a former service member to learn more
about the program visit
warriorcanineconnection.org Tanya J
Powers Fox News
[Music]
put the power of over 100 meteorologists
and a worldwide resources of fox in your
hands with the fox weather podcast
precise personal powerful subscribe and
listen now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts subscribe to this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for
your Fox News commentary David Marcus
what's on your mind in July 2020 amid
the George Floyd protest sweeping Across
the Nation WNBA star Brittany Greiner
vowed not to take the court during the
national anthem for the entire season
with the much welcomed news that the
Biden Administration has secured her
release from a Russian prison in
exchange for notorious arms dealer
Victor boot it's reasonable to ask if
Griner will commit to no longer
protesting the anthem of the country
that secured her freedom
despite the insistence by some on the
left that America is systemically racist
and homophobic the entire country had
the back of the black and lesbian
basketball legend everyone was pulling
for her and her family and for almost a
year the pressure to get her out of
Russia came from all corners of society
the Absurd nine-year sentence that
Greiner received for possession for a
few canisters of cannabis oil appeared
to be a clear effort by Russian
President Vladimir Putin to gain
leverage and it seems to have worked in
exchange for her the U.S sent back to
Russia one of the world's deadliest arms
dealers who was serving 25 years for
crimes including the targeting of
American citizens
well some Republicans argue that Biden
should have gotten more out of the deal
specifically the freedom of former
Marine Paul Whalen we can all agree that
the U.S paid a real price for griner's
release not just by putting boot back in
the killing game but also by sending a
message to other foreign dictators that
absconding with American citizens can be
a powerful bargaining chip that's a very
real Danger
but Griner is an American one of our own
and as a nation we have decided that
whatever the risks of releasing boot the
priority was her freedom
speaking of Freedom one of our greatest
freedoms is the right to protest Greiner
and every American can and should
protest if they see Injustice such as
abuses of police power against blacks or
anyone but by making the national anthem
the symbol of that protest Greiner
painted the whole of America as the
source of these abuses
that same America that has now
sacrificed so that she may come home
this summer Greiner penned a handwritten
note to President Biden which included
the following
on July 4th our family normally honors
the service of those who have fought for
our freedom including my father who was
a Vietnam War veteran it hurts thinking
about how I usually celebrate this day
because Freedom means something
completely different to me this year
indeed
Brittany Greiner is not being asked to
pay a debt to her country for the deal
that ended her torment it's simply what
America does for Americans
but perhaps going forward when she
chooses to fight social injustice she
can remember that the United States is
not just a place where Injustice exists
what country doesn't have that but also
that America is a place that has gone to
extraordinary lengths to save her life
welcome home Brittany Greiner America
loves you
standing for the Star-Spangled Banner
would be a very welcome way to show that
you love her back
I'm David Marcus author of charade the
coveted lies the crush the nation
[Music]
listening to the Fox News rundown and
now stay up to date by subscribing to
this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
listen ad-free on Fox News podcasts Plus
on Apple podcast and Prime members can
listen to the show ad-free on Amazon
music and for up to the minute news go
to foxnews.com
from the Fox News podcasts Network FOX
News rewind financial crisis 08 a look
back at the biggest financial crisis
since the Great Depression the market is
not functioning properly subscribe now
at foxnewspodcasts.com